your mission critical applications
depend on correct data
that's why developers rely on relational
databases which ensure
data consistency however last
generations databases weren't designed
to handle today's
scale and availability requirements in
today's episode
we're talking about how spanner provides
the highest level of consistency of
any distributed relational database at
unlimited scale
consistency is one of the main reasons
to choose a relational database to back
your applications
strong consistency guarantees ensure
that data is correct regardless of how
it's accessed or updated
let's say you have a banking system that
transfers money between accounts
consistency ensures that the debit from
one account and the credit into the
other either both succeed or both
fail this simplifies your applications
and lets your dbas sleep well at night
when it comes time to scale however
traditional relational databases require
you to give up many of the consistency
protections that made them attractive in
the first place
this is because they rely on techniques
like sharding to divide the data across
multiple instances the overhead required
to manage these shards
typically forces operators to choose
between performance or consistency
in addition highly available systems
need to maintain
multiple copies of the data in case one
of the shards goes down
for many applications uncertainty in the
form of replication lag
or eventual consistency is a recipe for
complicated code
and tricky bugs this is where cloud
spanner can help
spanner is the only distributed
relational database that provides
external consistency the highest
consistency guarantee
this means that all changes in the
database appear from the outside as if
they happen sequentially
this dramatically simplifies a
developer's view of the data
no more sharded queries timing bugs or
compensating logic
to your application spanner looks like a
familiar single instance database
it handles the complexities of ensuring
consistent transactions
even as infrastructure scales up or
automatically fails over
spanner is fully managed so your
operators don't ever have to worry about
sharding or replication
so how does spanner provide external
consistency without sacrificing
availability or performance at scale
let's start by imagining your database
resides on a single machine
in this case it could use a simple
counter to order incoming transactions
however a single machine can only scale
up so far
beyond that you'll need to distribute
the work across many machines
keeping a single counter would be a
bottleneck between hundreds or thousands
of servers
spanner avoids this by allowing each
machine or node
to keep its own counter using a clock
but not just any clock using a
combination of gps
atomic clocks and google's dedicated
fiber optic network
spanner's truetime technology ensures
accurate ordering of transactions
without expensive centralized
coordination
truetime simplifies the work that
spanner has to do to provide strict
external consistency
this streamlining translates to better
performance and higher availability for
strong acid transactions
let's take a closer look at how spanner
manages the data involved in those
transactions
spanner partitions each table's data
into independent chunks
called splits each split is assigned
internally to a server unlike
traditional sharding
these splits are completely transparent
to downstream users
spanner automatically optimizes its
split configurations to balance out
workloads
and avoid hot spots when a split is
under heavy load
for example when updating the inventory
of a popular product
spanner resizes and rebalances the
affected splits to avoid overloading
individual servers splitting and
rebalancing happen completely behind the
scenes
dynamically adjusting based on your data
and workload
to avoid a single point of failure each
split in a regional instance is
replicated across
three isolated zones spanner uses the
well-known paxos consensus protocol to
ensure that everything stays in sync
even as the storage and machines change
underneath
during a write spanner first determines
which split
or splits will be affected each split
has a leader among its copies that
coordinates locking and replication
the leader assigns a timestamp to the
transaction using truetime
and tells the replicas about the updates
using paxos
once a majority of the replicas
acknowledge the update the leader
directs them to apply the changes to the
data at the agreed-upon timestamp
leadership updates dynamically within an
instance again to avoid single points of
failure
for a query that doesn't make any
updates spanner avoids the extra
overhead of taking locks
accessing an always consistent copy of
the data at the most recent time stamp
combined these optimizations ensure
consistency
and availability at scale spanner takes
distributed consistency a step further
with multi-region configurations
multi-region instances replicate data
over two or three separate geographic
locations
for example the us europe and asia
this added replication up to nine times
provides
industry-leading five nines of
availability
but doesn't all of this come at a
significant cost to performance
while the underlying work that spanner
does to ensure consistency and
availability is not free
you only pay a performance cost for what
you actually use
in other words if a query can run
without locking
it will or if a write only touches one
split it will bypass a more expensive
two-phase commit
this means that your applications will
continue to perform as they scale
with all the same consistency guarantees
by partitioning the data into splits
spanner can grow beyond a single machine
and resolve queries in parallel
improving scalability and performance
by replicating splits over multiple
zones and regions
connected by google's dedicated network
spanner is able to remain
highly available up to 99.999 percent
even under the most grueling workloads
finally by coordinating updates using
truetime and paxos
spanner ensures that your applications
only ever see a consistent view of the
data
the best part all of this is handled
transparently for you behind the scenes
so there you have it the magic sauce
behind spanner's consistency
at scale thank you for joining us today
for this episode of spanner
database unlimited
you